hey guys just want to let you know about
some dates uh september 16th through the
18th i've been saying the wrong date
apparently but it's september 16th
through the 18th i'm in phoenix
october 28th i'm headlining the brea
improv
um you can catch me out on uh the road
with segora
uh tommy's taking me out we're gonna do
some dates together i know we're doing
like a vegas weekend in october
um there's a california run in like
january
and just go check is the midwest there's
ohio there's west virginia just check it
all out all right
this episode is brought to you by liquid
iv
ritual go henry and truff more on that
later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
ryan zickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all your
social medias
look i want to continue to say thank you
for your support in
under a year we grew over 100 000
subscribers so thank you
uh please continue to subscribe just it
means nothing to you
everything to me hit the subscribe get
the numbers up it's a free easy way to
help and then you'll get a reminder
that you get audio on monday video on
tuesday all right
honeydewpodcast.com is the website go
get your merch
everything's restocked it's all there
for you all right now if you're new to
the show
you know what we do over here we
highlight the low lights uh these are
the stories behind the storytellers
very excited to have this guest on first
time here on the do had a great craft
feast episode as well so go back and
listen to that
ladies and gentlemen please welcome paul
version y'all welcome to what's
up dude so great to be here with you
buddy finally yes
i know we've been trying to do this you
know what like being from new york you
come out to la and you're like
what what podcast you know like because
now it's not like because now
it's like what podcast you're gonna do
right it used to be like i got to do a
set
you know now it's like no man like and i
never i was telling you before
before we got on here i want to do
podcasts of dudes that i love
guys that i met that i clicked with
instantly and uh when we met in arizona
we were cool we kind of you know stayed
in contact and everything
and uh so i'm happy to be on it happy
for your show growing man thank you
brother uh yeah but no
this was this was one that i was like
i'm gonna hang out with sick man so
you're right too because i just worked
with uh segura uh
a little while ago and they were like
what credits do you want when you go up
i was like you know what
say you've seen them on your mom's house
podcast
the joe rogan podcast and he hosts the
honeydew podcast
yeah and i thought to tom cause tom and
i you know years ago we did bray and i
was like
we would say back then you'd be like
whatever the [ __ ] credit was
hbo comedy central what love whatever
the [ __ ] it was
yeah and but it was all tv and [ __ ]
and now
it's all i was like i purposely want
just and
you could hear the applause of people
with the podcast
yeah but when when they used to say
you've seen them on comedy central
once i'm like yeah that's all that [ __ ]
you know what i mean nobody no
nobody no and it's funny like when i was
just in tampa and i heard an intro that
you had in la here might have been that
show we were talking
yeah i heard like when they said you're
when they say the podcast
and i was just in tampa and they were
like oh versy effect and anything better
and you just start you're like oh [ __ ]
like they don't care about
comedy central or netflix or or hulu
like that like
it's like oh that's nice but they're
like where can i hear because this [ __ ]
has taken over radio
and journalism i i am now teaching as it
should
yes as it should i am now teaching a uh
through lana's um non-profit i teach
culver city high school kids every
wednesday a podcasting class we created
a curriculum we teach them we've given
them two episodes we had the mayor
of culver city come in we had the chief
of police at culver city come in
i teach six kids we created a whole show
for them
and we're submitting it to the school as
new curriculum
and get rid of journalism y'all yeah
y'all just out there writing lies anyway
fake news why write it when you could
say
it yeah no that's that's actually i
don't even think that's probably
you're bringing up future podcasters of
the world man like that's actually it
should be actually because
this is radio in a different form this
is radio and tv in a different this is
radio and tv in a different form and
it's taken on because people need
people want to see this because it's
real [ __ ] so before we get into what
we're going to get into with
you please plug and promote everything
and anything you'd like
so guys i got uh i got two podcasts
right now
uh the versi effect podcast which this
is kind of the versi effect 2.0 because
before it was just like audio
like you know it was just like talking
to the fans that came out to the show
but through
everything that happened at pandemic we
got a studio now my producer andrew
themlast so check out the version effect
bill burr and i co-host
a new podcast right now called anything
better which yeah we kind of we [ __ ]
about sports and stuff but it's
everything it's life and
we have such a good time people are
loving the rapport that me and bill have
my youtube channel you could uh go to
paulversey.com for upcoming shows
speaking of that july if you're in the
connecticut area july 23rd i'm gonna be
at the fairfield uh
community center theater i think that's
the name of it but just go to
paulversey.com
i'll be in fairfield connecticut a great
theater actually on july 23rd
uh doing my first theater gig october
22nd
at the uh wilbur theater in boston
and there's going to be a lot of shows
leading up to september because i will
be shooting
my first special yeah this and i'm sorry
my second special
wow yeah i was going to say go go check
this first special
first special man really went viral we
have over 10 million views
online during the pandemic i'll say this
which is on comedy central
doing my second i should say yeah after
pandemic i felt like everything was
reset
i'm just saying first for everything but
second special
and uh my good buddy pete davidson uh
who you all know from snl
you know movies stand up pete davidson
is going to be making his directorial
debut
uh on my special he he you know we've
been friends for a long time he saw
chunks of the material and was like dude
i want to be a part of this
so that's going to be going down and uh
looks like the middle of september
there's going to be a ton of dates
before that so just for all ticket links
available paulversey.com uh like i said
clips of the versi effect and stand up
on my youtube
go to anything better has its own
youtube channel and just check all the
stuff man thank you
all right yeah um so we're going to get
into
we're going to tell a story a little
differently today so you actually went
through
some serious depression back a couple of
times
yes hit you it's hit me a couple of
times so um you said i believe the first
time you were in college
right yep so let's talk about that how
old were you what year is this and where
where are you in college all right so i
was
i'll tell you how it how i think it led
how it led up
so i was um living in a different area
before
high school i was living in lower west
chester
i it was a smaller school i had friends
i was playing sports they were grooming
me to play football a lot
they were you know it was just like a
smaller community things are going good
and then boom my mom and stepfather hit
me with we want to buy a house house we
had like the second level of someone
else's house we we want to move on with
our life and we got to move like an hour
like upstate and and you're how old if
i'm i'm like dude i'm like going into
eighth grade man
like i'm like it's like it's like so
like i'm like the man i'm not even
kidding like
like senior middle school fifth sixth
seventh i was like
[ __ ] i was i was you know like being my
friend we were like hanging out with
girls and the first time you like saw
a vagina we rode our bikes home like
animals like can you believe that
that's what it looks like you know like
we were like the [ __ ] dude you know what
i mean
we were the [ __ ] and oh we're gonna play
football and then
i remember being in like seventh grade
and they wanted me
to become the quarterback in eighth
grade so like the last quarter of the
season they put me in
i had like two plays for like 20 yards
and everything and then like
i kept saying like mom we can't move
we're gonna move and we went up to a
school
that was big and it was like upstate the
school system wasn't that good but my
parents got a nice like ranch house up
there
and um and i realized to get popular
and since it was so big and it was the
country there was a lot of drinking and
a lot of partying and being at the
parties and who's going to do a keg
stand
and all that [ __ ] who's going to smoke
the weeds that was what the cool kids
did
so i didn't want to play sports with
those kids because that
my guys were the guys that i came up
with young through grade school and now
going into junior high and now the
sudden it's this big school kids i don't
know
and so i started to party and i started
to hang out with older kids
so like the older kids big nominee
you're cool like they took me under
their wing but it was like
parties and weed and and so i was like
girls and drinking
and i just got into that and i became a
bad student
you know and i was really distracted but
i was smart like i remember one time my
english teacher
every like i don't fry we'd write an
essay and she called me out of the class
afterwards and she goes why why are you
in here why are you in the lower english
and i go she goes these essays are
fantastic
and why are you and she called me out of
class and i never forget she said shout
out to ms scorer man she was she's
really changed
she changed things for me and she goes
i'm gonna put you in the higher class
but don't make me a fool and i went from
a c
student in the low class to a b-plus
student
in the higher class because she just but
like i was just i was just distracted i
was lost man i wanted attention
i wanted to be liked you're an only
child no no i had brother but i was just
i was young like my parents divorced
when i was my parents divorced when i
was five
and my brother was 10. and it was like
1982.
my father's 100 sicilian you don't do
that what are we [ __ ] nuts like
that's the thing what do we not we don't
do that
you know your mother went crazy she went
[ __ ] chris because of her dude i'm
[ __ ] five dude
dude i was in the back of my mother's
car and he goes your [ __ ] this
was some evil [ __ ]
okay evil oh [ __ ] i'm like i'm like dude
i live with it
like i like like i can't [ __ ] dude
like i was a little oh dude my dad is
[ __ ] my dad's another [ __ ]
i mean evil he actually one time he
actually said to me he goes
some he actually said he goes i'm gonna
tell you boys my brother's ten i'm five
he goes i'm gonna tell you boys the
devil invaded us
and i was like what and he was like the
devil came to us okay
in the form of your mother for a little
while
and i'm dude i'm [ __ ] like dude i
just want to go to the movies
i mean i'm trying to i want i want to go
to the movies i wanna i want a [ __ ]
like are we gonna go to playland like
are we gonna
and this he's just going you [ __ ]
believe this [ __ ] and i gotta get out of
the car and live with the
i gotta live with the devil mom is the
one who decided to leave
my dad was a my dad was a big wig at aig
okay he's you know he was but my dad was
my dad was about like you know
fur coats and matching really matching
rolexes no oh dude my dad showed up to a
pizzeria in 1100
gators i'm not kidding dude okay this
[ __ ] my dad
showed up [ __ ] you know like fur
around the neck
oh dude my dad my dad my dad would
always go let me tell you something okay
no no i mean i like i like the one thing
i took from him is like i like the
higher
hotels i like like yeah yeah i like the
luxury
pants yeah like we go to a nice cigar
lounge and it's nice leather chairs and
chilling
my dad is like if a man doesn't have a
watch
or good shoes he's a piece of [ __ ]
dude i remember one time we were in that
we were i'm not doing my dad
he told me you got to put that on here
my dad is big my dad is big with uh my
dad is big with jewelry
yeah big with you yeah and you know my
dad you know nice guy old school time
racist you know
oh dude my dad still can't believe my my
father still can't believe obama was
president
your mom no my father still can't
believe obama was president he talks
about it like it was katrina like he
talks about like it was a natural
disaster yeah like it was
you know you know and i'm just like all
right dad like he's just so but here's a
nice like he's not even like racist like
when he when he's around people of other
cultures he's so nice
he's just so old school that it's almost
like this grandfathered in
you know thing and he's actually like
believe it or not he's got
wisdom but he was just he's just another
dude man my dad is just another
but what's what's he come from where
he's rolling up in furs and [ __ ] does he
come from poverty where he wanted to be
something my grandmother is proud of
that or does he come from money where
that's sort of in the mighty how you do
it yeah my grandmother
my grandmother came here from sicily at
10 years old didn't speak a lick of
english my grandfather
was sicilian but born here in america
but my dad it's like that soprano saying
my dad was the firstborn sicilian
son and american and so it's like he's
jesus
you know it's like everything like my
aunt like didn't probably you know my
aunt moved out to denver and stuff but
like
my dad was like like well you know
just like the the son you know with him
just you know set with him so
um that that's kind of the thing and he
was just always like
you know money was a very like you know
i remember one time we were in
my dad bought a new jaguar in 1982 black
xj6 white leather
beautiful car and we're pulling out of
like our scarsdale tudor you know i
would have lived a whole different but i
wouldn't be here
listen to me if they stayed together and
i would have went to some prestigious
you know what i'd have been professor
versus i would have been a [ __ ]
chiropractor
yeah because i'm not gonna be a real
doctor so
so you know but no i remember we're
pulling out of the driveway
and our neighbors just go where are you
guys going and i rolled the window down
i was excited to tell them i go we're
going to mcdonald's but they're going to
say no you don't tell them we're going
to mcdonald's
like don't tell me go to mcdonald's like
it was that [ __ ] and my mom wasn't my
mom didn't care about like the
my mom didn't care about like my dad
wanted to buy a boat my dad wanted to
buy my dad want to buy like a 800
900 000 house in 82. today it would be
like worth 4.5 million dollars
so like he was on the way and and uh and
then the divorce came
and me and my brother went my mom we
lived in a one-bedroom apartment
you know with my mom my mom would sleep
on like the couch in the living room me
and my brother had this big room
and my dad couldn't get over it so he
would say you know he would say wild
[ __ ] about things it wasn't really
handled
where would he live so he would always
live like
around where we were at but an apartment
as well yeah like he would get like so
he had the problem
he he he would get an apartment you know
he would you know always had nice cars
like
he would either yeah benzes he would
have mercedes and [ __ ] but he would be
an apartment near us
and uh yeah man and then things just
changed then i moved
then i wanted to be then it was like i
would drink and
uh you know so it's time to go to
college
this is before the first and i decide to
go away
this is embarrassing to say i decided to
go away to community college
my step-son is about to do it yeah he's
telling me going to santa barbara i'm
going to live on campus like what
what junior college has a [ __ ] campus
like you talking about apartments like
right next door he's like yeah like
don't call
campus yeah like yeah they had like the
apart they called them the meadows they
were apartments
like on like next to the building yeah
it was like you know two floors and [ __ ]
yeah community college yeah exactly and
uh it was up by syracuse
and it was like a school for like soccer
and lacrosse to really move on to a big
school but i didn't do either
so you know but they were like it's a
good you know and then like oh it's a
party school
so so what was your uh what did you set
out as a major originally so what i
wanted to do was i wanted to do
like when i was probably 18 19. i always
did talk about as a matter of fact
in high school i would tell from they'd
be like paul you're funny man your
stories
we had this like delusional thing one
day me and my friends are going to go to
new york
and get me an agent because i told good
stories and i was funny at parties
and we were literally talking no you
know we're going to do we're going to
get on a train like i was gonna walk
into an agent's office
as an 18 year old and everybody go do it
you've got this kid and then i was gonna
be a
but i think it was like sports and maybe
commentating
maybe some sort of like communications
degree where i would either like
just talk sports and stuff like that
which ironically i do a podcast where i
do that so
kind of that's involved but um we went
dude and i just
it was an absolute [ __ ] show
i mean girls knocking on our door with
kegs going you guys want to put on
on a wednesday you know hammered i would
you know smoke weed
i would do all kinds of just stupid [ __ ]
i remember one time i drank all night we
wake up at three in the afternoon
we had finals once and my buddy mike was
across we had two we were in the same
room
so my bed's here there's a desk between
us and his beds there and the alarm's
going off we go [ __ ]
and we sit up and was like dude finals i
just go nah
and we just went back down no oh yeah no
school no class
it was party it was we having a party
tonight and all of a sudden do my
my mental i just collapsed
how long end of the semester probably
the first
i would say like towards the end of the
first semester
like like middle to end of the first
semester dude i started to like have a
mental
what start what do you start suffering
what happens
like just fatigue in the body and mind
um shaky i was very nervous and anxious
i didn't want to
to really be around anybody i would stay
in bed things started to get bad and
then
so what happened to me and and i learned
this on the on the next breakdown in 16
was
a lot of health things my mother was
diagnosed with stage four
cancer when i was in 97. so i'm in high
school i'm about to go to school
i'm a senior having a hard time seeing
if i'm gonna graduate on time
uh and and i remember i woke up one day
and i hear either what is hysterical
crying or hysterical
laughing in my mother's bedroom and
unfortunately uh
it was it was uh crying and she's pale
and she goes i don't know i just can't
get up and i was like well listen if you
want me to go to school
she goes no go to school and then i'm in
like fourth period gym and they ran up
to me and they go listen we don't want
to alarm you but
you know and i drove to school at the
time my car was in the parking lot you
know your mother's
being rushed to the hospital you need to
go home and i went home my mother was
there with uh with a friend and my
mother was
looking bad and she dude she was on her
way in an ambulance to the hospital and
i said you want me to go and she goes
don't come with me in the house
to the ambulance go and i was like i had
a job at a pizzeria i go let me go tell
the job i'm not coming and i'll come to
you
and do my mother threw up like a huge
amount of her blood count in the [ __ ]
ambulance
and she goes there and they're asking
her if she wants a priest or a [ __ ]
like they're asking and i get there and
she's she and then they're like it could
be like a bleeding ulcer come to find
out my mom has a tumor
in her stomach and long story short the
best part of this story
is that my mom would have cancer in her
stomach they'd cut her open take it out
then it would grow back they'd cut it
out take it out but after four surgeries
you just can't keep doing that
and then little dots started to appear
on um her liver
okay and uh now it's bad now
now i start to the only way that i can
mentally prepare is i start to envision
excuse me my mom not around i have to do
that like that was the way that i coped
with it
and i started to like almost like kind
of picture my mom's funeral it was
really fun my older brother wouldn't
accept it
and two months before my mother's last
relapse now she's in stage four
two months before her last relapse the
dana-farber institute in boston was
working on a test drug
for people with leukemia and uh
they said that it started to work with
my mother had a cancer called gist
it's a gastrointestinal very very rare
and they worked it on a hundred people
they tried it
out of the hundred people it started to
work on 26 of them
out of the two my mother was in the 26
then then it started coming back
and then it started only working on 10
of them my mother was in the 10.
okay my mother has not had cancer active
in her body to this day your mom's still
alive my mom's a lot
[ __ ] yeah my mom's alive and my mom got
to see
weddings and my mom got to see grandkids
yeah and also that she was in her 40s
and now she's in her 70s
and this drug now it wipes her out it
her immune system
you know but you know small price to pay
so
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor liquid iv
the hot summer months are here and we
need to be proactive to keep our body
fueled up
and hydrated making hydration a priority
helps us feel healthier on a day-to-day
basis
and it fuels us to be our highest
potential one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounces of water hydrates faster more
efficiently than water alone not only
that
but the product tastes great with
flavors like watermelon strawberry and
lemon lime
sounds like summer doesn't it now i just
got the straw i
look you know i love the orange one i
talk about all the time but the
strawberry one i just got is bomb
and it's so good i've been taking them i
take them every day
uh i've been giving them the neighbors
they all love them they're all yes
morning look what i mean i'm like dial
it back bro
uh it's great stuff and it's better than
just pumping sugar in your system
liquid iv hydrates faster and more
efficiently than water alone it contains
five essential vitamins more vitamin c
than an orange and as much potassium as
a banana it's healthier
than sugary sports drinks there's no
artificial flavors or preservatives
and there's less sugar than an apple
it's made with clean ingredients
non-gmo vegan and free of gluten dairy
and soy liquid iv
is on a mission to change the world grab
your liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or you can
get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com use the
code honeydew
at checkout that's 25 off of anything by
the way
anything you order when you get better
hydration today using promo code
honeydew
at liquid iv.com our next sponsor is
ritual we deserve to know what we're
putting in our bodies and why especially
when it comes to something we take every
day
rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients
in bioavailable forms your body can
actually use what you won't find are
sugars gmos major allergens synthetic
fillers and artificial colorants
plus the fresh taste and delayed release
capsule design
make taking your vitamins easy all right
i take it every day
i'm on a monthly subscription forum i
get their monthly ritual
daily vitamin i take it every day and
one of the very few things i can
actually
get a flavor of is the mint flavor it
has
it's got this refreshing flavor it's
wild looking you got to check it out and
it's not
they already tell you it's not filled
with all that crap that you get at the
store
all right ritual is designed with your
life stage in mind it's now available
for women men
and teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed
to help support different life stages
ritual makes
healthy habits easy your multivitamins
are delivered to your door they are
every month with free shipping always
you can start snooze or cancel your
subscription anytime
and if you don't love ritual within your
first month they'll refund your first
order you're going to go buy them anyway
why go get them just get them right here
i'm telling you you get the key
nutrients without the bs rituals
offering my listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com honeydew
to start your ritual today now let's get
back to the duke
i think now looking back when i would
get really depressed and down
something was wrong with me medically so
i'm going like and i said like uh and
but in college
there wasn't really like other symptoms
when you get older there could be body
symptoms
so i was just looking at my dick right
because i was like oh is something on my
dick
and i was like yo so i called my mom and
i was like i think you know
my fur coat i'm going to the doctor god
damn it
so i would i would i would be like you
know i was like you know i was
you know like if if i was sexually
active in college like i would i would
automatically be like you know i called
my mom crying and i was like
you know i think i got hiv she's like
paul like you you don't
and i'm like something's wrong why am i
she's like you're having a you don't
understand like you're having a
a breakdown here something no you don't
understand mom i'm sad
i just want to come like i can't be here
and like she was like i hate hearing you
like this
excuse me and it was like she saw it you
know
dude i got something in my throat i'm
sorry
so anyway it's called trauma yeah yeah
it's me holding back tears no uh
so yes she was she was like crying going
i hate seeing you like just hearing you
like this
so it was time to pack up and go home
but i was down dude
let me ask you during this time dude are
you just talking to your mom are you
talking to your dad as well
i'm talking to both but when it comes to
this [ __ ] your dad's more like
quit being a [ __ ] [ __ ] my no my dad
would just be like you my dad
was just always you know you'll be all
right right you'll be all right you'll
be you know you'll be fine like my mom
was like you my mom went through mental
stuff you know
so yeah so it was just like i just
couldn't be happy and i'm home and i'm
sad and like i didn't want to be around
friends
i was just really just in a bad bad
place man and
and then i had a friend kind of talk to
a friend that got like
not religious but well he got religious
and then he i saw him out one time and
he just goes you're lost huh out of
nowhere he said that was weird
he just saw me saw my mind and then he
talked to me we went back to my house we
had a nice like talk and he tried to
help me
and stuff and i felt a little better the
next day i felt like oh man like you
know
whatever it was like not to be like was
that the spirit like the way it happened
the way it came to me my mom was like
you look better you look
you know like he he saw it in me and he
goes you know what i'm going to take
paul home
and i didn't even expect that guy to be
there he's supposed to live in florida
at the time
and he ended up being there and uh he
was an old friend from high school so
i started to slowly come out of it i
rested i didn't drink
you know my i have very bad ocd and
always worried but it goes medical i
think now looking back the reason why i
told a story about my mom is probably
because my mom was sick
exactly but i didn't know right sure so
it was always like something bad
i had a friend of 26 diet cancer his mom
died of cancer
my mom had cancer so it was like i was
like oh man something's gonna happen to
me
you know and i think that that's what
was happening so then i
came out of it i got stronger i got
better
i was clean you know no not even you
know no booze nothing no weed nothing
and i started to actually go to the
community college near my house and i
became like almost like
almost a 3.0 doing well and then i
started doing
stand-up and i dropped the [ __ ] out i
was like
i'm out again yeah like i heard i heard
the professor talking trying to be funny
and i was like i want to be talking
and then i would do like bringer shows
in new york and industry nights in new
york
and that's when like around 21 i was
like all right i need to drop out get a
sales job and do stand up
okay and then 21 year old kid
doing that uh and i just got my first
manager six years in
i started working my way up and stand up
then all of a sudden some
some big axe would see me i remember one
night judah friedlander goes dude man
he's in the bathroom i know he was
saying you're real funny
and then all of a sudden bobby kelly was
like funny
and then bur i met bill burr and bill
burr was like
you know hey man you're funny man keep
it calm i'm gonna refer you to this one
room
so all of a sudden things start going
great and i'll fast forward now to the
to the to the to the 2016. yeah
so now i am i was opening for burr on
the road
i was do in every comedy club in
new york city uh and it was around 2016.
i got off stage in canada at a like a
hockey arena with burr
and burr goes dude i never saw you do
any of that stuff and it's
great he goes you're getting ready for a
special man and i was like
yeah i feel something you know i feel
good and my my first uh
hour album night at the stand came out
in 2015
and and it went real well so now i'm
just i'm getting better and things are
going good
and i have this big massive uh fourth of
july party every year
comics family friends and dude i'm not
trying to talk [ __ ]
but like i blow up the sky like [ __ ]
nobody
no no residency does what the [ __ ] i do
like july
like it's july like 17 7. like
i had [ __ ] coming up to me
going dude how's this legal
like like dude i have friends going i
don't know like how is this at a
residency dude
i mean my neighbor threatened to shoot
me he said my neighbor my neighbor said
next year i have a gun
i [ __ ] it up dude i had illegal
rockets from the bronx
in my house i had [ __ ] that was on the
macy's barge like
in a [ __ ] backyard dude like the
circumference of
bonfires just i mean we were lighting up
the sky we had this great party
but the night before uh ari shafir and
joe barton came up we drank a bottle of
whiskey we stayed up by the fire until 7
a.m
then the night of the 4th i stayed up
again until seven a.m drinking
so now my mind's getting weaker but i
noticed something was happening with me
where i just wasn't feeling right
okay uh i do a show in connecticut and
like everything is in slow motion and
i'm having anxiety attacks
on the stage you feel everything slow
down that's why i [ __ ] love you dude
because i i think
i'm on stage at the funny bone in
hartford
okay there's 240 people i'll never
forget it was like a
aaliyah janine you know alia janine she
was she was a
she was in the adult porn industry and
then she moved over to
doing stand-up and she ran this room and
she goes oh jersey why don't you come
out to the thing there's like 240 people
there
my buddy dave temple's there and dude
everything's in slow motion
and i'm talking to them in the green
room but i'm not there yeah i'm not
there dude
and like my head was hot and i'm trying
to concentrate and i never forget i'm on
stage
on a thursday night at the funny bone i
had some fans come out to see me
and i remember killing and watching the
table right to the right
laughing hard and i felt like i was next
to my body
so i was watching myself and i wasn't
there
and dude it's only an hour and a half
drive from there to my house
and it felt like three and a half hours
and on that drive
i convinced myself that i had a brain
tumor i convinced myself
i said there's something in my brain
there's tightness here so what was i
left something out there was
i'll have these dizzy spells on stage
all right so there would be tightness in
my forehead
but then i i noticed that i would either
have to touch the stool
or touch the wall and i always have it
and i'm going i'm going
dude something's wrong so i came i told
my wife i go babe the tightness in the
head and she goes paul you got to stop
i have a tightness in the head and then
i went up to my mom and my mom saw that
look in my face
and like here we are back to where we
were and she
she's like paul is in such like i would
do it i couldn't like get it and i
couldn't make myself a sandwich now
weeks are going by
what do you mean i was i was i was just
so
are you bedridden i was like in bed in
the thought of getting up
i never see here's the thing like i'm an
upbeat positive dude
okay like all my friends like giannis
and and bartnik and burr they're always
like oh versus the easygoing
you're the easy one you know and so when
the depression hits somebody like me
it hits even harder because now i'm in a
place that i'm not you know now i'm in
this realm that i'm not used to like
what the [ __ ] is that i'm sad
and i'm and i'm never so i'm happy you
know at the time are you married you're
married with two kids kids yeah and so i
my mother i go to a doctor that i used
to go to when i was younger
i was like i got to bring something's
wrong and he goes you know what i think
he goes i think you're fine and i think
and he's like but for you and they had
to like get approved to get me because i
kept having this pan
they had to get approved to get me a
brain scan and dude i went for a cat
scan on my [ __ ] brain
and i'm in there and i'm and i'm doing
everything i can to not lose it in this
[ __ ] tube
and my brother's outside everybody's
gonna hate seeing you like this and i'm
going
and in my mind i'm literally going now
ryan this is no [ __ ]
and it gets worse than this dude you
know i'm going there they're seeing my
tumor right now when i get out of here
they're going to be looking at me like
you need to go to the hospital
wait while you're in the tube i'm laying
in here
this guy or girl out here is seeing my
tumor when i come out
they're gonna look at me and you gotta
get the [ __ ] out of here and they're
gonna cut your head open tonight
yeah that's our anxiety though that's
tight ass
too don't open your [ __ ] eyes
and and one time i had emergency surgery
once near my appendix they thought it
was my penis it was something else so i
have gone to the doctor before
and been told uh you need to go and so
they cut that out
so now in my mind i'm like oh they're
going to see this [ __ ] so
i get out and they go thinking about
your kids i couldn't look at him like i
couldn't look at my kids because i
didn't think i was going to get out of
16.
and i'm staying in the guest room and
stacy is like daddy's sick so the kids
just knew daddy was sick
now mind you stand up is going
phenomenal people are going dude you're
ready for a special
so that's another great question so i i
only canceled
i cancelled one weekend and like a
handful of sets and then i would just
power through
so there was one where i was so when it
got so bad when i was in the heart of
and when i i found out when you're in a
clinical depression
they say a clinical depression is about
12 weeks like it could be
like 90 days and i was in it and um and
what was hard was it was like it was
hard for me because like i said i'm a
positive dude
so like i knew i wouldn't kill myself
and that made it worse
because like i'm just gonna live in hell
because i was in hell i know exactly so
i was in [ __ ] i'm not going to do
that you know like i didn't have the
comfort to be like i'll [ __ ] eat a
book like i didn't have that i would
never do that to my family and i don't
want to i want to live
because i know how nice it could be when
shit's good exactly you know now i got
to give a lot of credit
to yannis pappas one of my closest
friends he would come up to the house
because he he lives
near me now dude he came on yeah and
told uh
his corona story about being at your
house with the ambulance
and his wife chasing it and everything
yeah he went through it and you know
what
i helped him through that that's what he
said and he helped me through like he
would come up and be like dude you gotta
understand like this is in your head so
you know then um it was it was just a
really like when you came out of the
mri yeah come on they say to you they
were like
cat scan came back it's clear it's good
now how do you feel at that moment
now this is when this is when i knew i
was in a real bad spiral
so i unbeknownst to me at the time i
have a seat a disc issue
and the disc issue causes weakness and
um what's it called numbness numbness
and also like when it vibrates
uh like uh tingling and all that yeah
tingling but also like it makes you like
jerks your uh
your your muscles would like jump up
like like a yeah like
it's like your muscles will like spasms
spasms okay
so now i'm just i'm googling [ __ ]
yeah and
so now i'm going now i'm going that
doctor's that that doctor who studied
for [ __ ] 10 12 years he's out of his
[ __ ] mind
okay i know i'm sick and nobody now
everyone's crazy to me
so i'm going to my wife i'm going don't
you [ __ ] see look at me
because i couldn't accept i didn't have
the control i wanted control
so the only way i can control it is by
knowing what it is i couldn't i didn't
know that it was just me
so like it it got so bad you know after
that like i you know the oh you're fine
you don't have nothing in your brain and
anything but i was just
so low and like to the point where like
bill burr
is you know um my you know not only like
a best friend but he was like a mentor
you know and he would
like when when i was coming up and and
you know he was somebody that was like
you know when you're a
comic and you're coming up and that
guy's going dude he told me things i
would do that
i was like what he'd be like dude you're
gonna start selling out comedy clubs and
you're going to go to theaters and i'm
going dude
i'm making 450 this week right
like i'm not like nobody's booking me
like what are you and like but
but you know then he became like family
and he's my son's
he's my son's godfather that's great and
like so so
he was away for this so he would call my
wife
because i was just so down like i didn't
really want to even talk to anybody you
know giannis would come up and like kind
of sit there with me
but like i didn't want to talk to
anybody so so bill would call my wife be
like how's he doing
bart nick would check in like you know
just just friends of mine
that were either in california or
someone just kind of checking in but
like kind of from afar
but they didn't know how dark i was they
didn't know that i would go out with my
wife
and being like you you know you're
sitting with somebody that's not going
to make it out of the year
like that's i would be sitting there
eating like we went to a wedding and i
just had to tough through
and i was just at it like i'm like
drinking wine going these people don't
like i'm not going to be
like y'all know i'm dying right yeah
yeah like that so
my [ __ ] arm is my arms you really
felt like that huh dude
no no no i didn't feel like that i knew
it in your mind
this is the last wedding i'm gonna be
these people yeah i'm here for my wife
i'm resentful and [ __ ]
i should be in bed but no i'm i'm so so
i'm just i'm just in a bad place and
you know comedy clubs are like dude like
things were going like that's the thing
so
what i didn't realize is what anxiety
can do but here's where things got crazy
so i'm having like weakness in my arm
now at the time i don't know it's my
neck i don't know it's my dis my wife is
going paul
you have issues with you you know and
everything gets magnified with anxiety
and my i felt like my right kept saying
that my right leg was weaker so now i
google
and i'm googling and i start saying well
there could be muscle atrophy it could
be ms
right that's i had numbness in an arm
one time thought it was them
i was worried it was now i'm in the
lowest part of my life
okay having a hard time looking at my
kids who i love beautiful kids i'm not
just saying that dude you look at my
kids like everyone says my kids should
be j crew model i have these beautiful
little kids that love me to death i love
them
i'm so lucky as a man to have this i got
a beautiful wife who supports me and
[ __ ] and i
can't look at my kids because i don't
think i'm i mean it was so [ __ ]
brutal
i call my wife from the bathroom and
she's at work
oh okay no no no no she's at work and
i'm in the bathroom
and i go i'm not joking i go i'm almost
crying
and i go babe babe i figured it out
now all these doctors yeah test i go i
figured it out
okay i go i have ms
and she goes what right now i'm like on
the bowl and [ __ ] and i'm looking at my
phone in a full-fledged depression
and i figured out what the [ __ ] i have
and i diagnosed myself
with one of the most horrible muscular
diseases and then i'm going
well there's other lists on here there's
als there's musculatu
something that's the twitching and dude
it got so intense when she came home
i was making her stare at my leg to see
if one leg was thinner than the next
like it already said like it's yeah just
but it gets
like a balloon but but but i go i go to
is my right calf a little
and dude i got her so convinced she goes
all right it might be a little stiff
naturally they are she goes she goes she
goes
she goes you're right she goes all right
fine your right one is think and then
that's all you do i'm laying in bed with
her and i
i don't i got so ex i was like i'm dying
i'm dead
it's over and i went to bed i
i went to i went
and i go to bed and we go to bed almost
like holding each other
and dude i was so delusional and
convincing that i saw a tear come from
her i think she started to think i was
sick
so now my wife is going i'm living with
this dying [ __ ] i am
[ __ ]
i'm about to push his ass in the
wheelchair i got two kids
so so i i call i caught
i caught
paul you got to stop like my wife is
tough and sometimes i'll be like you're
not you're not
you're not being there the way i need
you to and she goes no i can't let you
buy into this [ __ ]
so she was a she might do my wife is my
wife is strong dude she's great dude she
really is she's strong she's beautiful
like my wife is a woman
that like you like i i did the married
the right woman you know great mother
and all that
but like she would be kind of cold and
i'm going like you don't [ __ ]
so my mom and i would talk all what's
something that she said to you that
really
still you remember like like when she
was trying to snap you into it
enough of this like i got you got kids
like [ __ ] like that and i'm going
yeah like but like but you but when
you're there when you're in that kids
[ __ ] yeah i was like dude there still
could be something in my head
you know they missed it i gonna say that
when i got two different calves
how you gonna look at me and say that
when my calves are different
in my [ __ ] legs i love to touch her
yeah yeah she started crying yeah
she was like
i'm going to see and that's what google
said that's what google said
you know so um i
call my mom and my mom goes i i can't i
go mom i need to
so i went to my mom and i i was i was
taking my mom had xanax and i started
taking xanax
and that would help me sleep and my mom
goes what can i do for you dude you're
in the
i was in the worst place like my wife is
like i don't know if we're ever gonna
get out of this
now we're talking two months okay now
we're talking two months
and i'm like struggling dude i'm
struggling to do sets
by the way i'm fun i'm i was at the time
i was funnier i wanted to ask you this
pause for a second i i had the same
thing sort of happened to me not sort of
it did happen to me at 2016 as well
uh from december of 2015 like all the
way for six months
yeah but like i found complete
solace comfort like
like you step out from of a storm and
you're just in this quiet space
and i'm still despite everything that's
going on that
that i'm splitting with my daughter's
mother and then i'm only gonna have my
kid half the time and i'm
doing math in my head like oh my god
that's only nine
years you know i'm doing all that
nonsense
um but on stage it didn't matter whether
i did
12 minutes or 15 or an hour
it's the only place in my life ever
where
no matter what the [ __ ] is going on when
i step
up there i don't think about anything
but that yeah
yes it just doesn't enter my mind it's
the most free
yeah i probably am in my life yeah and
it's and what happens is like you know
when your talent
takes over and the story takes over and
you give people joy
they don't know what you're going
through you know so you're in that art
and you're doing it and you walk off so
so that was
that was the thing when i did muster up
the answers the entire time during your
sets um when it like except for that
connecticut one like when i
once once i knew like all right like
i'm gonna just get up there and get
through the time my only concern
was if i got lightheaded i didn't want
to fall so i would just make sure but
that's i
when i got into the set i started having
good sets i'd be okay and i would get
through it and i would get laughs and
everything like that
but i was the funniest obviously that i
ever been because when you're at
that point like where we are right now
where i sit now with you
me and you and where you sit we're the
funniest we've ever been right now yes
right now at this moment and and in two
weeks it'll be then
so uh that was going good when i can do
it but
i talked to the doctor he goes good news
he just tried to get me out of it good
news your brains for everything like
that i go over my legs listen
if you want i can get you tests for your
muscles i don't think you need it
but i could get you a test i could say
so he sends me over to this asian doctor
i go to this [ __ ] place
and i go in and the asian doctor he's
got kind of an accent and [ __ ] and i was
like trying to explain to this [ __ ]
guy and he's just a doctor who's smart
and i'm in a delusion okay so he's
sitting in front of somebody who's
[ __ ] in a full-fledged delusion
filled with panic and anxiety and knows
he's dying and all these things and he
goes what are you worried about and i go
i go i got like ms some kind of muscular
thing and he goes what
and i don't know if it's msa like i got
twitching in my arms every time
he goes i'm going to tell you something
he goes i can give you a test
that's going to test your muscle
activity
[Laughter]
lift up your pant leg now uh
so he goes before i see a test take your
pants off
no uh roll them up so he goes i'm gonna
give you a test
that this is real dude this is how
[ __ ] nuts he goes i'm gonna
test your muscle activity you're gonna
lay down and i'm gonna put
needles through your whole body and he
goes it's excruciating and many people
after the third or fourth needle want to
stop
but i'll be able to tell you what's
and i go [ __ ] let's do it and dude i'm
laying on the thing
i'm laying on a [ __ ] thing like a
like and i start to become a voodoo doll
right
this dude's putting things in there and
ryan
when i tell you i felt nothing no
zero pain to the point where i didn't
even feel the initial prick i looked and
saw them in there
that's how you saw it in your skin like
i saw it in my s
and he would as he'd put it in he'd be
looking at the computer monitor to see
like my
and i never told a story i never told i
was gonna tell this story on a podcast
someday down the road but
i'll tell you because this is this is
what this is i never told a story about
the
about the muscle thing and the test i
took and he's looking and i'm laying
there
and as he's looking at the screen um and
he was you know he had that
doctor face looking really studying
and you know he's an asian dude so i'm
in my mind i'm like he's a little
smarter he knows i'm sick
like i thought he knew i'm sick quicker
than you know so i'm going you know
this guy knows and i'm laying there and
i'm going he's seeing some really wild
[ __ ] right now and
every time that's what you're worried
and as i'm laying on the table dude i
started to really convince myself and
tell myself
like how my funeral is gonna be and i
started there
i i started thinking about how my
funeral was going to be
would i know when i was dead in the box
would i
would people who would be there how
would it be i'm laying there as this is
happening
and that's where i am dude that's where
i was dude
and i'm waiting and then i had to go two
times for him two times for him to
completely rule it out
why so uh because you didn't feel that
[ __ ] on the first round no no with the
test he goes in order for me to really
tell you
there's uh there's three different tests
i could give you one on one time and two
on the other
so i leave and he goes come back and i'm
just sitting i go to my mom's one night
how long is cause i had an incident too
how long from
leaving till you go back two days
and i'm at my mom's because my mom lives
right near the doctor
and stacy was probably better off just
with the kids you know not having
[ __ ]
sick dad in the room yeah right and um
i go back the last day and my mom gives
me a big hug and she goes if you need to
cry cry and i was like no no i'm not
gonna cry you know
and um i i went there and i lay down
and i'm going through the needles again
and he's looking at the thing again and
i know i'm gonna finally get results on
this day
and uh he goes excuse me one second i
have to walk out of the room for a
second
and like he goes i'll be right back i
don't know somebody called him in
and when i tell you i'm not trying to be
funny here on your show
when i tell you i was absolutely
convinced
that he left the room to call my family
and to say this is this is it listen you
got me believing this [ __ ] now that's
what i'm thinking so he's going out
he's he's calling he's saying to have
his mother and wife be here when he gets
out
because we need to sit down and tell him
we need to sit down and tell him what's
going on with him and send him somewhere
to get the pr
ryan [ __ ] convinced come not thinking
it no knowing it and i'm going this is
it now this was the answer i told you
i knew it was something wrong it was in
my brain i knew it was something just
brought some donuts
yeah and it was like a phone call so he
comes in he comes in and he's very nice
and he knew i was mental he knew
he saw in my face i was hurt and uh he's
done and he goes that's it
and i sit up and he goes you can put
your shirt on and i put my shirt on
and he looks and he goes based on my
tests everything is fine
you're okay you have everything and
he just looked at me and he goes un
unfortunately this is this is here
for you okay and he pointed to his head
you're like a brain tumor
i told
i want my [ __ ] mri money back no uh
so so um he and i looked at him
and my eyes welled up and i said thank
you i said you don't know what you did
for me
and i almost you know hugged him and he
looked at me so
i went home and i talked to my mom i
called my wife and i think like that was
kind of the beginning
that was the beginning of the healing to
know wow like where my mind really went
i went home it still took me a couple
weeks i slowly
so this started just so you know this
initially hit in july
of that summer and by september i
started to go
maybe i'm coming back and i remember
giannis going dude when you come back
you're going to be stronger than ever
and almost a year
to the month i started to feel better i
shot my first special for comedy central
i'll say this
and it became a hit for them and it was
like and i remember
ben i talked about it i talked about it
on stage i said you know when you're in
the darkest place
especially for a happy you know guy like
me to to go there
and and to know like the things that
your mind can do and what i didn't know
is anxiety can give you a physical
symptom people don't understand that
if you say your shoulder is [ __ ] up
and there's a [ __ ] bump in your
shoulder
you'll find the bump which is probably a
bone
but you'll find it you'll it will start
to hurt and it's all because of the
power of the mind and
i think it was a culmination of
everything i think
that my life at the time was a whirlwind
i think that i was
tired and beat up like i was in college
again i think my mom getting sick
i think the fact that tightness was in
my head so
it could never be something wrong with
me i needed to know a reason so it was a
medical thing it could never be
well paul you're just [ __ ] up right
you're just [ __ ] up you're mentally
[ __ ] up you have ocd
anxiety and depression and this is your
problem it couldn't be that
because i'm killing i'm doing good i'm
with my so it's almost like there was
nothing
and and and through honestly man through
love through friends
through doctors through through support
my my wife
mother uh giannis pappas who i have to
give credit to during this time
um it all it all started to come back
and then i felt [ __ ]
bulletproof and whenever i would feel
something creep in i would you know
there are times where i get a little
you know even now we all have it but i'm
like you know what relax
it's not that you know there were times
after i got covet
i was coughing up stuff and and my mind
was now able to go look man
you had covet you have a cold now relax
you're fully vaxxed
you [ __ ] you got through it and and
now i'm able to go out on the road and
focus at the task at hand
go on stage you know the best stand-up
i've ever been doing people are saying
this new hour is better than the last
so like now i'm able to and like listen
i got kids man and and life is
life is short but it it you know you
said something when we were off the air
that really hit
me when you were like you're gonna feel
different at 35
and you're going to feel different and
you're a different person at 30
at 40 than you were at 35 and i'm sure
at 50.
at 50. you know and hopefully you are a
different better person as we get older
like oh well
you know 20 year old me would would have
been out there doing this and that
25's not 30 is not you know yeah
and i think i think that like you i
think
getting older i think at the ages we are
right like i'm i just turned 40 a couple
like i'm in my early 40s right
and and it definitely changed and it
changed with like
because i always used to laugh when i
had friends in the 40s i'd be like these
[ __ ] are always yawning
every one of my friends in the 40s
[ __ ] tentacles
what the [ __ ] i'm 36. yeah like i'm 36.
this motherfucker's yawning
i mean it's 9 30. people are like i'm
tired i'm like oh i'm 48 man i get tired
this is what my body does not but one of
my buddies after i was like 41 he's like
i picked him up he got in the car he's
like
what are we doing what the [ __ ] i do i
stretch and crack my back like let's get
it let's take a quick break and tell you
about our next sponsor go henry teaching
your own kids how to be responsible with
money doesn't have to be tough go henry
makes it easy to teach kids a lifetime
of financial skills helping your kids be
financially literate
can make a huge difference in their
future and go henry can help
i got this little card from my daughter
i'm putting money on it teaching her
about tax teaching about
how you use the card at the store
punching in her code all that stuff and
then we'll put money on it be
responsible like you do these chores
get 10 bucks and what's 10 bucks buy
let's go see what that buys and then we
go and use the card
you can keep filling it up look man i
didn't learn even that
okay we we learn how to write a check in
seventh grade
and you don't even write checks anymore
all right go henry's debit card for kids
and app for parents is an easy fun way
to teach kids good money habits it's
designed
to help young people ages 6 to 18 or
48 learn about money firsthand to build
financial independence
with gohenry they can use their card to
make purchases online
in stores order an atm and track
spending in real time
you can set savings goals make donations
you can help them learn to budget and
practice generosity
it's easy for parents it's simpler than
handling cash and allows boundary
setting
and flexibility you can receive
real-time notifications about how much
your kid is spent
and where all right it's founded by
parents with the mission to make every
kid good with money
it's got excellent reviews on the app
store google play store
and trustpilot so get started at
gohenry.com and get one free month with
promo code honeydew
that's one free month at gohenry.com
promo code honeydew our next sponsor is
truff
truff is a luxury hot sauce brand
inspired by the elegance and indulgence
of truffles truff's original hot sauce
blends black truffles
ripe chili savory spices and organic
agave nectar they're hotter sauce which
that's my favorite it takes to heat up a
notch with extra jalapenos red chili and
habanero
for those who demand the spicier things
in life and the white trough hot sauce
is infused with rare and decadent white
truffle it's the number one
best-selling sauce on amazon it's the
number one
best-selling sauce on whole foods look
man i just posted the other night about
it i steamed some shrimp
i threw it on there they've got so many
good products from pasta sauces
olive oils all of it their bomb is so
good
here's what you can do get 15 off
site-wide all right
plus free shipping with the promo code
honeydew at truff.com that's 15
off of everything at t-r-u-f-f and
that's f
as in fantastic dot-com promo code
honeydew i promise you're going to like
their stuff
now let's get back to the duke the mind
is
is is poison sometimes i i went through
my own thing it
so after my daughter's mother told me
she wanted to split it was
october 2015 where a year my daughter's
a year old
and all that come of the oh my god you
know control
and my kids are going to be around other
people and this and that and then
boom i get kidney stones then boom my
legs start clotting and then they don't
know they're telling me
it could be leukemia and lymphoma and
i'm like you know my doctor's like i'm
going to send you to the oncologist
don't panic i'm like already i'm
panicking yeah yeah and then a blood
cancer doctor he's like yeah i'm like
yeah i'm panicking he's like but it's
right next door i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] where it
is dude the fact that they even tested
you for that i would have just thrown
myself in a guest room for another two
months
so check this right so that's this is
why i asked you how long it was so
[ __ ] i go in and this doctor and i have
this conversation this dude's cool
[ __ ] he's like look man i don't see it
too often
like that both legs clot like this like
and it's funny because they ask me at
first they're like
is anyone beating you at home like who
who's coming at me
who's coming at me listen you know
nobody wants if somebody
i wish somebody would hit me right now
i'd love to get some anger and
aggression now
yeah yeah that's [ __ ] at least
somebody beat you up so uh
that explains it guess what this is
i'm in and out of the hospital three
four different times they can't figure
out what the [ __ ] it is and it's
progressively getting worse and i
remember coming home
and i i mean this is my darkest um
and i remember coming home and look at
my daughter's mother and she's like what
is it today and i was like
look they think i might have leukemia or
lymphoma i've got to go through a bunch
of these tests just
can you just can you just bag off can
you just back off because we're still to
like i haven't have to move out [ __ ]
it's christmas it's thanksgiving i'm
going through it
and um the doctor gives me
his personal cell phone number and i go
oh my god he's like what i guess is the
most nervous i've ever been in my life
he goes what do you mean i go
a cancer doctor just gave me you're
you're allowing me to interrupt your
weekend if some [ __ ] goes
to this motherfucker's boat on saturday
night oh yeah right and i'm like
you want me to contact he's like look
you're yeah i guess there's a normal
number for what your blood
levels and [ __ ] should be and i was like
seven times higher and he's like
i'm gonna put you on blood thinners now
we're just gonna bring you he's like
it's my belief i can reset you to zero
and then you'll be good to go i'm like
all right he's like
but you gotta come back in two weeks i'm
like for two weeks that's why i asked
for two weeks i'm walking around every
day doing stand-up going to work doing
whatever
a parent i'm single parenting wondering
if i'm about to die
and never see this little [ __ ] kid
yeah yeah i'm
losing my [ __ ] that's that's mental
prison dude
that's mental prison it's mental torture
even the two days that i went in my
thing it was just really like the xanax
got me to sleep and [ __ ]
or made me at least calm down but and
you know what's funny is like my wife
you know my wife uh she goes hey yeah i
went to the doctor she goes
this is how strong she is she just plows
through because she's got that i'm not
i'm mediterranean i'm a [ __ ]
passionate [ __ ]
sicilian greek my wife is like finnish
swedish
german irish they go yeah she goes they
found a spot on my lung they saw
something in my lungs so i'm just gonna
they're just gonna test it to make sure
and then never talked about it
i'm a [ __ ] so i'm a [ __ ] do my wife is
like i'm like a spot on your
lung i was like do you want to go to a
[ __ ] do you want to go sit somewhere
i'll [ __ ] like like do you want to go
to a bed and breakfast i'll take care
like we don't know how much time you got
and she's [ __ ] working and [ __ ] and
taking care of the kid oh you need to
take care of kids like having her [ __ ]
together
and me and i think it now looking back
like now i'm not really
like it is like i just learned like life
dude i want
if i could tell this one story man cause
this this was something that let me
this is i think we also know like you
get more you know mortality right you
know
well can i say that i want to finish
this story because this is what this
lady said to me
oh sure i walk in yeah and um
she just looks at me she's like how are
you feeling i'm like i'm exhausted i
just i'm here to get these damn results
and i don't know how to feel
and then um she's not supposed to tell
me
yeah and she goes i saw your results i'm
like oh my god can you tell me she goes
i'm not supposed to i go will you tell
me she goes you're good i go i am she's
like
you're [ __ ] good oh [ __ ] she goes let
me and i was like oh and i'm just
relieved
at that point i am so like oh god
and she looked at me and i've said this
before on the show and i'll say it again
because it's one of the nicest things
anyone's ever said to me it's one of the
most powerful things that
everyone's ever said to me and it was a
positive for both of us and she looked
at me she goes
what are you doing after this and i said
i'm just gonna go home and
relax and she goes go celebrate and i go
yeah you know whatever she goes listen
to me
go celebrate she goes it's my job every
day to tell people
they have cancer i have to come and tell
people they have cancer the thing you
feared most
and today i got to tell you you didn't
you go celebrate that i still get chills
every time
and i'll never forget it hit me and i
was like [ __ ] yeah i'm gonna go
celebrate tonight then i'm gonna drink
i'm gonna smoke i'm gonna have a good
meal i'm gonna celebrate
life tonight dude that that feeling and
and this is uh
if we ever uh if we ever do this again i
had a four-day cancer scare when they
took this thing out of my that had
emergency surgery and
for four days i waited for it but when
you find out that you're good
and and what people don't understand is
you take for granted not being in pain
we take for granted ourselves
dude pain
i remember i had like a [ __ ]
stigmatism in my left eye and i'm like
oh am i gonna see that line forever
yeah that's like that's not and you
start to realize you're like yeah man
like you gotta
but but i think the the pandemic put a
lot of things into perspective like it
really did
as far as and when you asked me the last
question i'll get to that but i just got
to tell you this story
about my cat please i gotta tell you a
story about my cat okay
so i'll make it the the short of it is
this for my wife's 26th birthday i
bought her i got her this kitten
and she named it thomas and this
[ __ ] grew up to be a
[ __ ] 20 pound hall of famer but we
got his brother stanley the next day
because i a friend picked thomas and
then and brought him to me
and i go let me see if i would have
picked him so i went to see the litter
and this little gray cat all curious
like
that's the [ __ ] i would have got
so then we she i tell her that and
and now we have stanley and thomas fast
forward
16 years they've been to us with all of
our houses with our kids
both of them still together okay all
they knew and then we bring in the dog
and that's a whole other story but these
two cats were with us
for 16 thomas for 16 years and three
months and now he's gone
and and stanley who is still there now
and when i tell you i'm not trying to be
funny
hall of fa they left a dead mouse on the
welcome mat every day for a year
did they really different mouse
they just they crushed [ __ ] yeah thomas
dragged in a chipmunk
yeah i found out that they want to show
you as a gift i didn't know
so this this dude dragged in a [ __ ]
i'll show you the picture he dragged in
a chipmunk and i just hear my wife
downstairs
okay yeah good job and this [ __ ] big
ass [ __ ] is bludgeoned
and he's just sitting there like a baby
lying next to this thing that he just
beat the [ __ ] out of right
good job now now no cost is too much for
me with my cats
yeah okay or my dog they you you know i
told me and burr talked about this on
the podcast so i don't want to repeat
myself but i i'll get into the sip
i pay i signed a 400 resuscitate in the
middle of the night for my cat
resuscitate this and he was 16. i was
like i don't give a [ __ ] bring him back
if he dies i want him back i don't give
a [ __ ] i'll pay whatever it is
he's been with us for a long time and i
see thomas he started acting weird for
two months and he's laboring now
and he would be like this and this piece
of [ __ ] vet took
seven hundred dollars from me and then
two days later
took another 700 going i think oh it's
just i think we could help him and he
knew he was dying
and and that really bothers me he knew
he was dying but this big beautiful cat
who was my wife
in our family for [ __ ] 16 years and
i'm looking at him for two nights
and he's given the look and i'm going i
think this is the guy goes i drained all
this fluid from him he should be better
and he didn't get he goes he might be
better for a week or so i still pay the
700
to keep just to see if he'll bounce back
i'm watching him dude
and uh i'm just looking at him and i
just i know i go i can't make him go
through this another night
so i go if he makes it through the night
you know i'm gonna just because
sometimes there's different
scenarios people say let them die they
like to run away and
be alone that's the beautiful thing
people don't know about cats cats cats
are dope when cats die they're so proud
if they want to go alone so when and he
tried he tried getting out of the door
when a cat's gonna die whether it's a
domestic cat or a big cat in the wild
they're they go off alone and they die a
lot yeah it's
it's yeah it's like uh what's his name
uh in uh
young guns what was it uh what was this
[ __ ] uh blue diamond phillips
yeah uh chavez
he went by himself he leaned against the
wall he saw the [ __ ] spirit horse yo
don't sleep on young guys that [ __ ] with
it
it is billy the kid but anyway so
um i digress so um
i see him and he's laboring and [ __ ] and
i know i know that it's
it's it's time to go somewhere and talk
to the people and stuff
now my son you know that song by
marshmallow
uh this is some sappy [ __ ] but this is
like you know what i saw by marshmallow
uh
lately i've been thinking i want you to
be happier so i just thought it's a song
about
like relationships and [ __ ] my son goes
i don't like that song and i go why
because
it's just there's a dog in it and it's
sad now i'm really down and sad and this
started if i was in oklahoma city
performing and i knew thomas was in bad
shape i thought he'd bounce back i came
back and i knew
that it was probably going to be the
last time i ever go away and see the cat
again
and i'm looking at him and he's he just
was in the same place he was done
he was done and uh i go let me just see
what that song is about before i take
him so i'm laying on my bed
and i play the marshmallows video like a
dick and it's a little girl the [ __ ]
video is a little
girl oh dude and i just the day i'm
taking him i go let me just let me
wallow in more pain
let me [ __ ] let me just really [ __ ]
experience this horror
right uh i don't know why we do that
when i was afraid to fly i would watch
plane crashes just to
meet you yeah yeah let me let me i know
i'm taking this poor thing which is
probably done
let me see this sad video that my son
doesn't want me to doesn't like because
of animals
and the song comes on i want you to be
happier and it's a little girl
who gets a puppy and she gets the puppy
she's sad and she gets the puppy and
she's happy
and then as she grows the puppy grows
and then she goes to high school and the
puppy grows and now she's about to go to
cup
and she's sad because they go to the vet
and they got to put this [ __ ] thing
down okay and i gotta tell myself it's a
video that dog's alive
okay yeah yeah yeah that dog's getting
residual
you sag after this that dog's getting
their parents are getting a check
i'm sitting there just getting the
medical insurance we're not getting and
i'm like
i'm looking at this little girl and then
the father comes in the [ __ ] room
and looks at the little girl and shakes
his head like this as if to say
that's all we could do and the dog dies
and i'm on the bed and i'm
i'm not crying but it's [ __ ] me up
and i put the phone down like all right
thomas we're gonna go and in my mind i'm
going well maybe you shouldn't have done
that
and i take the cat and i put him in a
thing and oh stacy it was stacey's cat
it was her gift
when she when when he was 20 when she
was 26 she goes can i just have a couple
minutes and she goes in and she comes
out and she's wiping her eyes and she's
crying
and i told her my daughter was very my
daughter's got that sicilian she has a
hard time she just you know
she goes from like happy little girl to
i'll kill everybody in your family yeah
yeah
and uh so i lucas is crying
and sophia's just like looking and
sophie thinks i think in her mind maybe
there's a chance he's coming back
because this has happened before
but i kind of know he's not gonna come
back so i go and the woman
at the i go to thing and the woman comes
out and i recognized her and she used to
work for that piece of [ __ ] that took
money
and i go yeah i really wasn't happy with
and she just was like she didn't say
anything but she was like
yeah i haven't been there for three
years and she goes but i remember you
and i go and she looks at him and she
goes let me take him in she goes i'm
going to just do an x-ray
i'm not going to charge you i want to
see what's going on and i was like you
know just tell me what you would do but
he's been it's bad
so i'm in the car and i'm sitting there
and i'm just [ __ ] waiting and i know
she's coming out
hand to god that song from marshmallow
comes on the radio i swear to god on my
children
i swear to god on my i would never say
that on the show i would never
i'm sitting in this [ __ ] driver's
seat dude i'm sitting in this driver's
seat
my [ __ ] i got a beard i look like a
[ __ ] and i'm sitting there
in my [ __ ] jet black beard my bald
head and i'm sitting in this [ __ ]
lexus looking around
and with p and all of a sudden lately
i've been and i'm going no dude no dude
you gotta beat this you got you
bullshitting and that's when i was like
there's something else in this life
this is by the way this is 100 true
i've never talked this is 100 true that
song came on an
hour and a half after i put myself
through pain on my bed while my cat was
in the bathroom
and i listened to and now it's on and i
know at that moment
she's gonna tell me he's done and dude i
got the chills right now she comes out
and she goes look she goes i took a
little sample of the fluid from the
chest and
she showed me it was like this it wasn't
good and she goes his
his lungs are floating in fluid his
heart is something and and i looked at
her and i said you got to just tell me
if it was your cat what would you do and
she goes i hate when people ask me that
paul but she goes
to be honest she goes i i would put him
to sleep he's just not he's not gonna
and uh so she goes how do you want to do
it do you want to come in we could do it
and
and i go out she goes you could stay
there for a little bit so i go into this
room i don't know if anybody's ever done
this before
but you go in a room and they have like
a a nice visiting room that you could
sit
they say you spend as much time with the
cat as you want and there's a doorbell
ring the doorbell when you're ready for
the [ __ ] executioner to come in right
so i go in and he doesn't even want to
be held like he's
he's oh what they first do is they shave
his they shave the
they shave like this i guess you would
say
and they put the catheter in of where
things are going to go and i'm trying to
hold him and he's kind of he wants to
retreat
and this is a nice cat and i know agar
he's he's i saw the look on his face and
he was skinny and stuff and whatever it
was i said it was probably from a cancer
that's been there and i think that's why
he was acting weird for two months he
would sit with my wife
but something was off and then he went
like under the table
in this waiting room thing and he's just
sitting there and i looked at him and i
go all right
so i ring the bell she comes in and she
goes all right this is how it works she
goes there's three shots
she goes one shot is going to like relax
him
the other shot is going to put him to
sleep
but he's alive and then the third shot
is the one that does it
so she's like what do you want to do and
i go
i go i don't want to be here for the
third shot i go can i hold
him while you relax him and put him to
sleep and then she goes that's fine so
i'm holding him
and dude his head is right here and i'm
literally his arm is dangling
oh dude and she comes over
she puts it in them and she's going it's
all right and all of a sudden as he gets
the first one he kind of goes up and she
goes that's just him feeling it
then she gives him the other one and he
just goes he's limp and i'm holding him
and the weird thing is when you put an
animal to sleep when they're alive
because he's still alive at this point
their eyes are open like they don't have
eyelids and [ __ ]
so like we have eyelids right but like
imagine if our [ __ ] was folded like so
they're just so he's so
and i'm holding him and i just i
remember i petted him i kissed him i put
him on a blanket and he just was like it
was like a stuffed animal
and uh i walked out and i couldn't even
do the paperwork or take the taxi thing
i just walked out
i left and uh but the weird thing was
there was something amazing that like he
lived the life that he lived like it was
this weird lesson that i never
by the way i'm done with that after
these other two die i'm done
it's too much i'm not doing this okay
i'm not i'm not i'm done dude i'm not
[ __ ]
it's horrible it is it's like it's like
they don't tell you that [ __ ] when it's
[ __ ] jumping in the window
yeah you know you know this thing's
licking and it's frolicking
you see the thing with its tongue out
it's [ __ ] eyes rolled back like they
don't
you know so that should be in the like
they should talk about that when you get
it hey you know it's gonna get real
[ __ ] up in 15 years right
yeah um but it kind of taught me a
lesson that like he lived like i said
like dude he would like kill birds and
robins and chipmunks and
he was a great cat and it just let me
like it made life go like
if i could live like that like if you
can get through that
and i know i'm talking about a cat but
it's kind of a lesson that that cat had
yeah or that i got from the cat and it's
like
pandemic put me there pandemic put me
there and going like
you know um life is like you got to put
things into perspective it was a good
reset for a lot of people
and it was because i feel like a lot of
people before pandemic myself included
were on a hamster wheel and we're just
doing the same [ __ ] and we're just going
and then all of a sudden you're like
wait a minute like
you got to put things into perspective
and you got to understand and appreciate
things and
listen i know that sounds corny and
cliche but but but that that corny
cliche
comes when it's supposed to it does you
know and and and uh
so it was hard you know and then right
when i'm over it and i almost celebrate
it i'm in the car picking my son up and
i get a call and they go
i just want to let you know we have
thomas's ashes whenever you want to and
i'm just going like [ __ ] can you
deliver it
like like like it's it's [ __ ] 20
hours i mean it's two in the afternoon
i don't need this mid-day you know i
don't need this midnight can you drop
the [ __ ] off at 2 a.m when we're
sleeping so
i could like yeah just like i want to go
get a roast beef sandwich i'm [ __ ]
out thinking of this [ __ ]
it comes with like a paw print it's like
what they give a picture and [ __ ]
you know so uh but yeah so
but it you know so but but you know what
we're doing good we
now we know that stan lee they're
they're they're real brothers so
stanley's that age
and he's older he's got diabetes and
[ __ ] so it's like i know
what to expect and i know but in a weird
way it was a lesson because i never
dealt
i never dealt with that before and i
kind of got to see that like he was done
he was ready
you know so uh yeah it was it was
definitely something that was was hard
to do
but that song coming on in the car gave
me something i don't know where you
stand on like
signs oh but dude i'm big on that too
like
that that was not normal and that that
song is two years old like that's not
that's not like because you know you
have a hit song like like the new
uh taylor swift joint that that's in a
rotation of 17 songs
so that keeps going this this [ __ ] this
is at a rotation down there but don't
worry
[Laughter]
yeah this is with the b52s and [ __ ] so
so when that came on
i was like oh [ __ ] she's gonna come out
and say
that he's done and i know now and and
i'm sitting there and it was just a
really unbelievable experience
that's great dude um look thank you for
coming
on and talking about this because what i
love about you like
you're just a youtuber dude and and you
too a lot of people have said like
um that this isn't the norm they like to
see guys like us who they consider real
guys or whatever the [ __ ]
that means yeah i'm talking about this
[ __ ] therapy
yeah battling depression and the mental
that [ __ ] torture that's up here you
know i say all the time
and this is men and women especially in
this [ __ ] city and even on tv
more and more i'm seeing people put
money into their hair and their face
and their lips and their cheeks and
their asses and stomachs and
and and not a bit of it into mental
health
yeah and and i look at it like these
guys that think it's like too macho
i almost think it's more of a [ __ ]
thing to to not address it
it's like because you don't want to see
the you don't want to see the oncoming
car
right you don't want to see that you you
don't want to face blindly walking
forward
just keep going it's like no man like if
you address that and get through it then
you're going to be and you're also going
to be it's also selfish because you're
going to be better for your kids yeah
we're going to keep drinking
think about you're going to keep
drinking through it you're going to keep
you know drowning the pain
you're going to keep being mean to your
wife you're going to keep being an
[ __ ] you're going to keep hiding like
holding this thing in it's like no i
want to address it because i want to i
want to move on but i appreciate what
you said and that's why i'm here like
like i said before you know we as a
comic you come out here
and it's like hey let's do podcasts i
wanted to i met you i wanted to do it
and and
when people listen to the versi effect
or they listen to me and and burst
podcasts like
one of the number one compliments i get
is wow man you guys just you know you
like anytime you hear the words like
real
or genuine dude like honest dude like
that's all that's why
i'm not here for like i don't want to
come out here even though it's part of
the business
and get on at podcasts just because
they're popular i don't know the people
and it's some hollywood [ __ ] and i'm
just being honest and if that hurts me
or that takes me a little longer then
let it take me longer but i don't want
to sit down with fake [ __ ]
and and this isn't fake this is really
valuable man especially
talk about it like it's funny to me i
just was we were
just talking to somebody the other day
about if whales have been on
how long have whales been on the earth
versus dinosaurs and they came after
dinosaurs but they've been on the earth
for
50 million years wow whale species
50 million [ __ ] years and i thought
like we're talking about the species
that's been on this planet for 50
million years and
if someone's lucky they live a healthy
hundred years
i mean yeah what is a hundred years when
we're talking about
50 [ __ ] it's a sneeze it's a it's
nothing it's
it's that's why that song dust in the
wind man we're we are we are a little
i i i don't know if it was sarah
silverman or somebody's like we are
literally a piece of lint
we are this is a quick ride i'll never
forget my grandfather
uh frank my my father's father frank
versi rest his soul he sat down one time
on the couch and he just goes
he was in his 70s and he goes paul it
goes fast
and now i'm sitting here you know 42
and uh you know i've definitely
accomplished a lot of things getting a
comedy special that did well
doing an album that did well and working
on the next one and just doing this as a
job
has been an amazing thing to to do but
like
there's other things that i want to do
of course but to just be here
two kids healthy thank god and you go to
yourself like
wow man like a decade's gonna come quick
like a decade you i remember my 25th
birthday cake
and i remember it said 25 ryan that [ __ ]
felt like two weeks ago
so it's like we are you're right man
like just last night i sat down
and wrote because you know they always
say where do you see yourself in five
years that old [ __ ] question i
thought
last night it dawned on me that my
daughter's six and holy [ __ ]
it's been five years since i've been on
my own as a single parent
with my daughter sharing custody and i
was like man
five years and i sat down i started
laundry listing all the [ __ ] i've done
in five years
and i was like god damn man i'm really
proud of myself and the accomplishments
i've made
personally the growth i've made
personally and professionally like i
i can't believe all the [ __ ] i've done
in five years and i'm not
the list isn't even done like teaching
and working with nonprofit and giving
back and all that [ __ ] is
and the number one thing you do man
seriously is like it's like you're
you're a
father to your daughter and like you
make that a priority man and then and
that's the priority i don't give i don't
i'm telling you the best credit we'll
ever get
is dad yeah i don't give a [ __ ] about
anything beyond that i really don't you
know this
you know we look at rich i will never
forget richard pryor passing away the
arguably the greatest yeah comedian
artist in our genre right
one of no doubt and he got a i think
someone else died on the same day and
got this little [ __ ] corner
and it was over yeah you know what i
mean and it's over and it's like
yeah we're we got we got a business full
of [ __ ] pedophiles and freaks and
rapists and [ __ ]
what do i want your goddamn approval for
i just need it from my kid
yep and the people out there god bless
you all that
night pants nation that love it yeah
well well who you know i think about
this too he actually lives in my
neighborhood i saw him jogging the other
day
but but who was in the business for 30
plus years mega star
and went away retired you don't hear
about him martin short nope
comedian david letterman yeah he did his
farewells [ __ ]
fighters foo fighters right and then
nobody even
that that catalog of work think about
that catalog of work
you know and he lives in my neighborhood
i see him jogging his head down his
beard
but like that catalog of work and when
it's over people go oh yeah man it's
great talk show and that's that's it
but you said martin short by the way and
i meant rick moranis that's who i meant
rick moranis bounced to take care of his
kids yeah yeah recently got stabbed or
some [ __ ] or something
i was going to like with like the credit
thing right where it's like it's like
you do that whole body of work and it's
like that's great and people know your
catalog and you did some iconic [ __ ]
that's great but at the end of the day
it's like oh yeah he lives up there now
i see him jogging all the time
he's dead he goes to this tv show and it
just makes you think it's like what's
important because
what what uh what will never be you know
i know i won't is be some 65 year old
single dude living in a
you know studio apartment wondering
about how many spots i got tonight and i
don't have
any [ __ ] [ __ ] that no way
no way i didn't want to be that if at
50. yeah yeah you know
[ __ ] that dude yeah well brother thank
you for coming on now something i ask
everybody's first time on advice you'd
give to your 16 year old self so now
knowing what we've talked about here
yeah what would you tell 16 year old
paul verdict i would tell
16 year old paul versi one
no matter how far away it is like if
your mind is to it
like if you keep your mind to it you
will do [ __ ] that you don't even think
you could ever do
and and two i would say what you think
is important isn't
like what you think matters now god
that's great
is it you think it matters now believe
me it's everything
it's it means everything it's your whole
life right now your whole world it means
dick yeah you know i unfortunately i
found that out you know
and the reason i would tell my 16 year
old self that is because now
i'm going i i would drive from upstate
new york away from my children
on a wednesday night we'd have dinner
and i'd have to rush
or i'd miss dinner to go do a 25
spot for a booker that i want to keep
booking me
on a wednesday night in the city an hour
away i'm losing money
and i'd leave these beautiful people
here
and guess what if that booker got hit by
a bus i gotta find the next [ __ ]
that's right
so imagine what i'm so i'm leaving my
family and all these important things in
my life that i'm getting up and leaving
and the pandemic let me know hey i
wasn't on stage for five months and then
i went to arizona headline and i was
fine
so perspective that that booker and that
approval doesn't matter
that comedian who's mentally ill judging
you doesn't matter
you know and and so so i would tell my
16 year old self
stay the course with blinders on about
what you want
because the rest is is noise uh my buddy
andrew thames who produces the versi
effect and anything better he goes those
other people are like
the people in a video game just walking
away like a si like they're not even
they're walking their [ __ ] but like so
so but you don't think that at the time
because when you're 16
oh i gotta get to that when i was 16 i
would i was like i'm gonna beat that
guy's keg stand tonight i'm gonna do 50
i'm gonna do i'm gonna do 91 seconds
yeah
i'm 91. you know yeah and and i'm going
like what
so i'd be like that's just not important
what's important is really bettering
yourself and not
other people's approval other people's
approval that doesn't matter
can can dominate us yes i've seen some
really
great comedians that both me and you
know that are in their
thirties forties and fifties that give a
[ __ ]
about some irrelevant somebody's got
seventeen
followers that just [ __ ] on whatever
they did he cares
yeah cares that like their whole life is
done and it's like and and you and you
either have a beautiful family at home
that you're
neglecting because of that or you don't
have any family because you're
concentrated on that so that's that's
what i would tell him i would tell him
like that that [ __ ] doesn't matter focus
on you and what's going to better you
and make you happy and everything else
is is outside noise that's great dude
yeah um please promote whatever you'd
like again yes
guys please go to uh my youtube channel
my website
uh paulversey.com has all ticket links
i'm gonna be
if you guys are in the boston area new
england area connecticut new york come
out to the wilbur theater in boston
i will be there october 22nd it's my
first theater show
it got postponed twice because of covet
it was supposed to be in june
then march it'll be october 22nd i will
be
at the fairfield uh community theater on
july
23rd in fairfield connecticut you can go
to that and i will be shooting my
special in september
directed directorial debut by my good
friend pete davidson
we're going to have a lot of shows
leading up to that ticket links will be
available there
go to my youtube channel thank you so
much for having me got it brother thank
you for being here
yeah um as always ryan sickler on all
social media ryan sickler.com we'll talk
to you all
next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you